có chuyên gia số số tuyên đền gây là bệnh lương hành quanh ham và có thể sảy ra ở mọi lưỡ tuổi.
Từ đầu năm, đến ngày, bà 1 tháng 5, thành phố chiming đã gây nhận mùi bệnh nghiên bệnh chăm mươi tảm các mắc.
Càng hơn, sống như tuy phẩy sống phần chăm, sau với cùng kiến nè mang những khung chăm lắm.
Hẹn tòa bộ 1 chăm sóng với tảm sá phương đã khu chi địa bàn điều đã khi nhận các bạn.
Đáng chú ý có hơn, nâng phần chăm số các mắc sảy ra ở vừa lớn.
Trong đá, nhóm tôi từ mi một đế mấy lâm và từ mi sau đến bà mi tôi có tỉ lệ mắc cao,
thật cho chuyên gia mật độ dân cư đâm, quá trình đối thị hoa nhàng,
cùng tất cả đồng của biến đối khi hậu đang tạo điều kiện thật lợi trong mỗi chuyên bệnh phát triển.
Ngày nghĩ tế khuyến cáo người dân thường xuyên vệ xí môi trình sống,
loại mỏ các vật dụng chương nước đọc, đẹn ngăn mỗi sinh sản.
Hì xuất hiện các số hiệu cạnh báo như sốt cao liên tục,
đau bụng nhiều, đau nỗi, tài trình lại hoặc trảy máo bất thường.
Người bạn cần đến cơ sửi tế đi đủ thăm khả và điều chỉ kiếp thơi.